our shout out tonight to the reporter at
The Baltimore Sun fouled up on a Sunday
afternoon phone call tip to break an
explosive series on the city's mayor who
resigned today just a few hours ago
the FBI searching the home and office of
embattled Baltimore mayor they came out
of the house with boxes and boxes upon
evidence when the FBI raided the home of
Baltimore Mayor Catherine Pugh it
wouldn't have been much of a surprise to
the readers of The Baltimore Sun at its
Statehouse reporter
Luke Broadwater who has a good source
and a good nose for when something
smells fishy
and sometimes tips pan out and sometimes
they don't you know you chase and but
this time it resulted in something and
frankly I was personally very surprised
by how how strong and harsh the reaction
was and how quickly things began to
change the tip involved members of the
board of the University of Maryland
Medical Center giving themselves liquid
of deals but the center refused to
answer any of broad waters questions so
that as I like to say set off my spidey
sense and I said well why well I don't
want to answer my questions you know so
I started calling around people in the
nose and soon broad water with the help
of other reporters documented how the
mayor who was on the board had received
some $800,000 for a series of children's
books healthy Holly many which were
never distributed or even printed we
also know that thousands of the books
are sitting unread in a warehouse at the
school system headquarters because the
school system says they never asked for
the books and they think they're of not
high enough quality to be used for
instruction so these books just sort of
showed up when the score says school
systems doorstep one day he unasked-for
unsolicited but the books are good for
lots of laughs it seems it is hard to
believe
Hugh's books were bought purely on the
base of literary merit reporters who've
read them have pointed out that for a
start she can't seem to settle on the
correct spelling of the name for one of
her main character educational
children's book about eating right she
spell vegetable rock we do know the
mayor had some books in her house and
her are never got any kids
as saw during the FBI raid they were
carrying out many of the boxes of the
healthy Holly books before she resigned
mayor Pugh had offered an apology to the
people of Baltimore for anything
unethical and then she launched into a
bizarre three-minute pitch for her new
line of baby clothing for the son it has
been a story no other news outlet has
come close to matching one of those
times when everybody in the newsroom
knows there's a big story so it's sort
of an all-hands-on-deck approach I mean
I think at different points probably
maybe 10 or more reporters have had a
byline on this story and serves as yet
another example of the value of robust
local reporting Lee I think like this
shows the Sun what the Sun at its best
and what the Sun can do yeah II we've we
have covered something that nobody knew
was happening we exposed it and there's
been swift change and ramifications that
would never have happened if it were not
for a strong local newspaper
so our shout out tonight to Luke
Broadwater and his colleagues and
editors at The Baltimore Sun following
up on that weekend tip not refusing to
let the story die that's our program for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you again here next week good night